you described you were bankrupt
literally bankrupt before breaking bad
yeah
which is crazy what happened was i spent
some time making some feature films they
weren't
great i didn't get paid a lot for them i
enjoyed directing them mostly
but i didn't really have direction i
didn't have a vision for these things
and this journey
as a director so i somehow got in this
financial hole and uh
got this phone call one morning from my
business manager saying you have to sign
this loan
to keep afloat you know and i was it was
a weird call howard i had little kids
uh
oh and i was you know life was pretty
good and i'm doing these jobs and
developing stuff and
and i get this phone call from the
assistant at the business manager and
she's like hi we need to get this 900
000 loan
oh and i go
what loan
oh you don't know about this
no i never heard anything about a loan
oh
oh
oh okay i'm gonna have someone else call
you
and she hangs up
and i go
what the [ __ ] was that do you start
grabbing at any job and then that's when
you get into that weird spiral of taking
jobs that you don't like i went to a
different business manager that was the
first move
and he was a great guy who i still work
with and he said look just look at it
this way money is money whatever you can
make somebody offers you three grand if
he offers you 300 make that money today
bring some money through that's all you
got to do if you just do that we're
gonna be okay and uh and i proceeded to
to live that way instead of being my
picky you know uh snooty self i just
said look works work let's do it let's
act
direct make stuff tumblr i pursued uh i
pursued commercials i directed some
commercials i had a good time doing it
and then i get a phone call they're
going to offer you a role on breaking
bad this show breaking bad not a popular
show or a big show at the time
and don't say no my agent says
and i was like dude i haven't said no in
a year and a half but maybe you didn't
notice that i still checked it out i
still wanted to know what the hell the
show was and i called a friend uh
somebody i'd been writing with reed
harrison and he goes oh that's the best
show on tv you gotta do that that's the
best thing there is